[Music]
alright guys you know I have an awesome
nation called the citizens of John
Mallia we have a question here and I
think this will apply to people beyond
just the citizens but how do you find
peace when everyone around you is bitter
and angry at the world and I think a lot
of us have to deal with this kind of
[ __ ] growing up especially when you live
inside of a house of people you can't
control and all that stuff
honestly murder no don't say that
no okay so here's the specific solves a
lot of time you know when Joe has to
check you you really [ __ ] up okay tell
me why not you either get rid of them no
dad or you go to jail and you're away
from them it's figurative ly speaking
murder because you kind of caught it
you're gonna get in big trouble saying
that out loud Nadine big trouble mister
by who by the public who the public I
mean world health organization let's
focus here okay so I live with my mom
and my and brother and as I as I had
gotten older I realized how mega t'v and
toxic they are it's their own unresolved
traumas or insecurities probably both
that seeps out since I'm the youngest
they don't take my criticism seriously
the bitterness they carry around damage
as my relationship with them because we
are not interested in talking about the
same things they only put their mouth to
use to gossip and complain and I feel
gross every time I'm around them how do
I remain peaceful during this quarantine
with them the answer is probably simple
but I feel a bit lost with what to do in
this situation I am saving up to move
out but the rate I'm saving it'll take
years well it seems like that you
figured out half this is the problem
which is knowing that much and just in
those moments to be aware there I'll
tell them I don't want to hear it right
all this negative like [ __ ] that they
can't solve
that's hard did I've told people that
before where they're like telling me
[ __ ] that's going on with someone else's
life when it's just like but it'll they
go and talk [ __ ] about you when you say
that no I mean that person at the time
if they're my friends hopefully they're
not doing that but sometimes they'll
like tell me about [ __ ] that's happening
that they heard from somebody else
that's just like all this [ __ ] I'm
just like just this is such [ __ ] I
don't even need to hear this right now
there's no point
how about vibes right sometimes you just
walk into a room you know yeah down here
you could smell the drama like when I
went to Germany was like that the whole
country yeah [ __ ] went down here oh yeah
we know what [ __ ] went down right you
thought that like good I was there five
years ago I went to Munich and I was
like baked goods I was in Berlin I was
like hmm
yeah the stronger knows yeah mmm plus it
it was foggy oh that's a sad way to do
it maybe not gonna gloomy looking back I
don't wanna you know I'm not an expert
on that but you know you know what
besides the mercedes-benz and a BMW they
have bad branding here in America there
are always the bad guys yeah well in the
movies yeah come on
let's think about a good movie that
focuses on Germany being good and you
have you buy random ass products though
it's always like German technology have
you seen that [ __ ] I'm like okay cool I
guess no butts on things I don't respect
that much like batteries I'm like you
don't respect batteries much don't care
that much that's [ __ ] up I don't care
about the engineers our latest
technologies toothbrush German batteries
does it put batteries in it that's a
little better
if I use a generic battery I feel like
it's gonna run out quick yes she's not
name-brand like man it feel like
Duracell is gonna keep me in for a while
do they pay you to say that Jesus
[ __ ] calm down I like better than
energizer bunny goes forever
well my powerful long erections are
powered by energizer
you do have a big dick I knew it no
that's not what I said powerful and long
duration not wait you should have left
long out of it well long meant link not
sighs he's the endurance [ __ ] this
question's [ __ ] rough like for me to
like say because it's your family and
you can't escape it it's because a
Quarren King [ __ ] do you do as you can
deal I cut my hand off of my life and I
love it but this is like look this is
your mom and your brother how do you cut
them off and you're in quarantine you're
stuck at home that's what other rooms
are for assuming it's a one-bedroom
apartment and the bedroom is your mom's
mom why do you live in such a small
space so then you add to the negativity
knock up my mama I have the perfect game
plan forever I won't say a word you
already said it in the beginning no was
it murder you said murder murder that's
choice number four that's that's five
minutes ago there Dean yeah you're way
past that so you already can't see this
one if you guys want me to uh say why
not [ __ ] it we have nothing else to do
you sign up at the URL that we don't
know yet but the the money masters yeah
you got to sign up money masters which
is our art program me and Steve's money
masters that's step one during that time
you're staying inside your room you're
away from these people because you're
learning yeah the longer you wait from
them the shortened amount of time it
takes from that year as you say you'll
take to save up plus the whole time of
you being like hey I'm gonna save up
because I want to move out gives you a
goal and gives you a direction to start
saving up even faster and not being like
how I'm gonna go spend money here
spending money here because the overall
goal is to get out of there that's
logical Wow
if all else fails number four we don't
we don't know we don't know
Redrum Redrum Redrum you have a special
Nadeem called fart and the deme disc
alcohol yeah
Nadeem the gene was my friend I won't go
that's too long you should only be three
letters I will get one same price no we
should go too deep the dream discount
code what we're doing it it's already in
how much off Tuesday yeah well I want
one too can I gonna be like geo if you
type in this code then you're gonna get
money back that's a log one of Geo if
you type in this code you're gonna get
money back can you do it I want to see
how if you will sign up if they get two
cents off yeah I want to do it it sounds
fun it's already 99.99% all from half a
million dollars listen I bought the
program myself and I never had more fun
just buying the program I had fun so
you're teaching us about money and you
ended up buying your own program that's
what you call investing in yourself it's
called money laundering geo and it
worked I don't think it works
I think it does and you can tell the IRS
that that I said that as well thank you
well it seems like she has her head in
the right place he does if you're trying
to save out to move out then obviously
your goal is to move out some people
don't even think about moving out and
they just continuously go through this
[ __ ] cycle well that and the fact that
she's so aware that she's like I
understand that they have their
unresolved trauma that it's coming from
them like it's hard not to [ __ ] fuel
their [ __ ] vibrations and they're
here they're [ __ ] noise but for her
to like try not to take it personally
that's [ __ ] the so there's this whole
thing right now that a lot of people are
moving toward and it's stoicism is oh
what's that mean
how did you know what I said yes I like
my dad who just watches TV when I come
home and doesn't say hi so oh guess
that's all guess that's all what is that
he translated it for me yeah what is me
she she said what's that
so Marcus Aurelius created stoicism
Marcus Aurelius right and the whole
concept is really about not letting
other people's feelings vibrations and
thoughts and everything anything move
you and what's happening to you and so I
think maybe this is what they're asking
when they say how to find peace when
everyone around you is bitter and angry
around the world I think you can't
control how stupid someone is so you'll
never be able
change like a lot of things maybe you
can you know Nelson Mandela Martin
Luther King a lot of great people have
right but then when it comes to you and
people around you the thing that you
can't control is you and how you feel
about how you react and as simple as
that sounds a lot of us don't know that
funny hard I get it because you said
stoicism yeah no well kiss-ass Oh
exactly
I'm not gonna teach you guys anything I
failed Spanish three times how far up
did you make it to Spanish what 1 1 2 3
times 1 2 3 times you're sitting in your
room and writing a list of [ __ ] you can
[ __ ] control and [ __ ] you can't
control and seeing that going like we
write I can't focus on the [ __ ] I can't
control em focused on the [ __ ] I can't
can just focus on you and your people
like you like this idea that we have to
worry about the negativity around us
look I get it but if you just focus on
your people that gave you positivity the
good people around you then you'll be
surrounded by like warmth but you're
stuck at home though losing your room
and they barge into your room they're
like here's this negativity no duh
you're like sevens headphones and you've
tuned it out you show them cuz now you
gotta have fun too number four number
five after murder then you go back to
them and you be even more about the
drama and gossip yeah double down on
their negativity yeah and throw it back
at them given their own medicine
I feel like they misery loves comfort
and they'll just bond even harder but
maybe so then she sees the light with
them and actually can bond with them
maybe they were just hurt oh you're so
good I mean as long as nothing physical
is happening
I feel like cuz my dad used to yell so
much when I was a kid that like
literally yelling now it got to a point
where when he yelled it meant nothing to
me so if you can build up that immunity
in yourself where you're just like this
[ __ ] happens so much I'm not because
she's gonna go through it again she has
to learn how to get through people like
that that's the whole price that you can
maybe condition yourself some way hole
she needs a break I think she needs a
break and she could come at it easy even
easier but she's stuck in quarantine
with them and I think that's the hardest
thing to do is wrong
you need to take a little vacation maybe
can you do that during quarantine go to
animation and we'll cross vacation very
nice yeah that always helps me to like
when you're in the mix of something it's
so hard to think outside and sometimes
you need to just physically remove
yourself outside looking in and then you
see it in your life it wasn't a big deal
man not to brag Nelson just got a 5 Star
Island really you mice Animal Crossing
with him I had a file for only three
weeks ago he just got one like yesterday
how about that who's five sire is more
better good for you though that
negativity effect you see how he just
did that he'd let the negativity get
inside his heart he stood by it
I wasn't being negative Steve don't read
into it I was really trying to like I
was really trying to understand I said
what the [ __ ] did you say and we all
know I have a potty mouth true well you
know just said Castle what does that
mean seriously though you [ __ ] it
[Music]